hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
Octodad dadliest catch now I played the
original Octodad long time ago and the
game was absolutely hilarious from start
to finish
if impossible to control so if
recommended me playing with a gamepad so
that's what I'm gonna be doing so let's
start a new game here it says continue
there but I actually didn't started
accidentally pressed new game when I
went forward not back to me the last so
I haven't seen any of it
it's called wedding bells as his part so
I'm guessing this goes back to the
beginning of Octodad before he gets
freaky with this lady and spits out
oddly human babies oh she's cuz you
can't run you can't run anywhere that
ain't him mr. GRU the wedding is
starting are you ready oh boy okay
lovely absolute ignorance on everything
so anyway I have no idea how to control
anything here okay so clear the table of
junk okay I'll remove the cushions okay
alright whoa Nelly there okay so what is
it oh my oh my okay so yes yeah yeah
okay
got it okay I'm getting it aha oh god
this is gonna be one hell of a
frustrating game I can assure you that
there we go I seem to be doing okay yeah
rip it right off it's it all mine
supposed to do that okay I will
gradually lift my leg and then what both
legs
oh my god oh my god okay oh okay so I
lift one with and then I move with the
trigger and then I gotta get my got I
gotta get my oh girl
do my tie yeah I'm 1/3 of the way
dressed and almost humanely presentable
I don't know what that means but okay
continuing on right leg and left leg
okay oh no no no no no was that a big
red button over there I want to push the
big red button what the hell is going on
here excuse me I just need to get my
tentacles over here what is this that
I'm spreading my crotch over Wow Oh
dance oh yeah always my wedding I
wouldn't get to dance
okay so dressing room here shouldn't
have activated the party balloons that
early but I think someone will forgive
me okay
go in ah there we go my tuxedo baby I
gotta look classy for my presentable
wedding looking pretty sharp they're
actually looking pretty soggy and sloppy
but that's besides the point
all right continuing forward into here
nope leggo that oh I need a key for that
where the hell am I gonna find a key in
the cake no that wouldn't make no sense
at all this is all game doesn't really
make any sense so I guess it wouldn't be
any stranger than can I move please it's
really really challenging it may seem
not that hard but this is actually quite
challenging oh look at that
hey good good is that good I don't know
if that's good I just destroyed my own
wedding cake but it was my wedding cake
to begin with let's turn off the party
for a moment and continue on
hey that banana looks like me anything
under here no all right then fine I'll
just move along my way is there any way
to change it oh yes I wanted to hug that
table please ignore me just cutting my
way through here excuse me I just wanted
to straddle all this get a good feel of
it around my crotch
it's really nice wait slithers about
okay so maybe there was something else
in the dressing room oh I see miss that
what kind of idiom I got it okay so I
just got to get this over to I'm sorry
oddly enough I'm starting to get the
hang of it like I didn't think that it
was possible but yeah I am actually
getting the hang of it hope it's a
bananas it's trying to sabotage my own
wedding here
hope I don't but oh but oh haha I didn't
give me this time big sign that note no
sign that okay sign the Charter mister
slither man not Slenderman Schlitterbahn
okay big leave gifts here kazoo my uncle
I think here's something along those
lines let go of Anna oh god what did I
just do why did I break that I was oh
god I wasn't even looking hang on I got
it there we go
slap that bad boy on here daddy I'm
ready to go
I gotta get past the hall door event is
this way she wonders why I'm always late
Oh looking good there friend if you
could just look into the mirror for nah
no I know you're too beautiful they even
look what God is amazing
I really like it this is so much fun I'm
so weird
okay yes yes I got it my wedding will
not be late
these presents that someone left in the
middle of the hallway
totally and conspicuously not to stop
any sort of squid octopus like creature
oh is that my hat can I have that
[Laughter]
beautiful not beautiful but you know
what I mean my beautiful blushing bride
[Music]
myself sit over here
pile of jewels precious jewel aha I
picked it right out because I love you
thank you I know what it just slipped on
a wrist all right then I'll take it for
what it is she's got uh slender wrists
Oh
[Music]
how does she end up having sex with that
thing and making the babies poses the
intro screen I was wondering what was
happening oh okay um am I in control
okay maybe not
okay I think maybe I got okay thank you
Chris Stallman you're awesome Alton
Kevin geissler Devin Scott's pumpkin oh
my god I missed it this game is amazing
I really like the original I played it
if it was only him it was a bit
frustrating mostly because I was playing
it with the keyboard instead of a
gamepad it's much easier with the game
cat still not easy but easier I guess
you Yolo did that spell out Yolo please
tell me you did bye-bye
this is totally ridiculousness total
ridiculousness but then again I
shouldn't assume that anything would be
serious coming from a game where you
play as an octopus father hmm is this
where I left off in the first game I
think it might naturally be get to the
kitchen yeah there we go okay just fling
that across the room nothing to worry
about there okay how do I here we go
it's like right trigger activates mode
how's it going the definite progeny of
my loins
yes okay all right hahaha
unicorns that's ridiculousness Mariano's
that unicorns don't exist and definitely
can't pretend to be human
[Music]
ridiculousness
aliens no way they could exist because I
am attentive to my children about being
a dad and all totally legit
I just bend my kid in the back in the
head with a gallon of milk pour how do I
pour oh god how do I go
[Music]
what happened there
something was very disturbing about that
exchange also kids bones made some
coffee
because I'm tired from working so late
okay normal for humans
Oh fine
know what we know this one - splash my
tentacle around a little bit in the
birdbath before I got to business I
guess you get out of here and then you
mix gonna scoot a little bit closer and
what does that even mean kid you don't
know what that means kid shut up I'm
trying to get this one week okay
god damn it okay whatever good enough
I'll blow on this one
no never mind I'm not gonna blow on any
of them I don't even know if I have a
mouth the hell is going on here okay
good yes did that whatever I did yeah I
believe you
yeah kid you're not just to lose a is
that a tie on there rum-rum-rum oh I got
a movement I forgot that I can hold on
to things while I move
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
blablabla yeah yeah yeah whatever kid I
know you're a lazy sack of crap uh-huh
you want me to suck it out with one of
my many suckers don't look at me like
that it's an octopus
he's got suckers come on I gotta figure
out a way to get that tie up on the
thing much harder than it looks
very frustrating oh I feel surgeon
simulator anger coming back on me very
harshly oh yeah that was beautiful
oh I fell into the garden but no worry
about that serve grilled burgers I have
to take care of something though get a
little hat see I gotta get I don't know
how to get up there in the world am I
gonna get up there can I get up there
let me just do a little sensual dance up
against this you like the splits I do
yeah you like that shed okay enough of
that
oh really normal what are you looking at
don't question me yes absolutely they be
delicious goodness what are you speaking
about
yeah I did it so good no keep you going
there drop that okay go get nice and
cooked I'm gonna pick that one up on the
ground later that's for mom she likes it
special that way okay this one's not
burnt I didn't know that I was supposed
to do them in one at a time whatever
he's got kid you get the slightly not as
clean version of
and I'm gonna just there we go
welcome I know I'm the greatest nothing
magic doesn't exist neither do aliens
unicorns oh of course not sweetie yes
stupid hey Oh animals did you see
animals what about animals they feel
emotional pains when their kids are
little bastards and they don't respect
them that's what they feel okay why do I
need to chop some firewood why in the
world do we need firewood in this modern
day and age hope I'm getting actually
pretty good at this I'm actually very
surprised at myself okay never mind on
that there we go nailed that sucker
right out of the park no not that well
yeah get that there jabots oh no
[Music]
delicacy for octopi
kids aren't you a little concerned about
this free trip to the aquarium
okay no no I know you think aquariums
are festering prisons of iniquity but
I've got to write an article for the
paper can't you make an exception this
time can I oh okay Oh groceries we need
to go to the grocery store we need
things like cereal for the kids sounds
suspicious we need so much cereal then
it's settled
we're all going to the grocery store
[Music]
aren't you healthy
aren't you just delightful all right
think that'll do it for this partner
okay all right hopefully that did
something there this was awesome
oh I love it so much well I'm getting
used to the wonky controls but after a
while it kind of does good I love I love
this game so much all right so anyway I
just played this one part if you guys
want to see the whole game me play the
whole game let me know in the comments
below I don't know if I'm gonna do the
whole thing but either way let me know
in the comments I'll probably do more
but I don't know if
do the whole game so just let me know
that comes sorry thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video I'm
going I'm going the distance I'm going
for speed I am not doing so well here